en esta ocasión quiero trabajar otra vez
la derivada implícita pero ahora de esta
función que al graficar la en
wolframalpha me sale esta cosa avisar la
que tenemos aquí y esta ecuación loca es
la ecuación he elevado a la equis de
cuadrada es igual a x menos james y
todos los puntos que satisfacen esta
ecuación son los que tenemos gráfica 2
aquí a la derecha por lo tanto lo que
queremos es la derivada implícita y para
esto voy a usar otra nueva anotación
ahora voy a cambiar de notación para que
vean que también existen otras formas de
llamar a la derivada implícita una de
ellas es tomar el operador de mayúscula
de mayúsculas no quiere decir ni más ni
menos que es la derivada con respecto a
x y bueno realmente lo único que he
hecho es llamarlo de otra manera por lo
tanto vamos a hacer la derivada
implícita tal cual la sabemos y bueno
también voy a usar otro cambio de
notación en esta ocasión en lugar de
llamar la derivada de ye con respecto a
x le voy a poner que prima y bueno la
derivada de una exponencial que está
elevado a la x
cuál es su derivada con respecto a x
bueno la función exponencial cumple que
tiene que aparecer esta función
exponencial tal cual por lo tanto lo voy
a poner aquí elevado a la equis cuadrada
y después hay que derivar la potencia es
decir hay que derivar la función a la
cual está elevada la derivada con
respecto a x de x día cuadrada ahorita
vemos quién es esto y bueno esto es la
derivada de la exponencial del otro lado
de la ecuación que es lo que me queda la
derivada con respecto a x de x que es 1
- la derivada con respecto a x de james
que es la derivada de ella con respecto
a x que habíamos dicho que en esta
ocasión le íbamos a poner el nombre de
ye prima y no se espanten solamente
estoy haciendo un cambio de notación
realmente yo prefiero mi notación
clásica es decir esta anotación este de
aquí y ésta de acá porque lo que está
diciendo es que estamos derivando con
respecto a x sin embargo también quiero
que vean y aprendan a otros tipos de
notaciones en fin vamos a hacer ahora la
derivada que nos falta a la izquierda
entonces aquí yo tengo que prima no sé
respecto a quienes nosotros sabemos es
con respecto a x pero bueno muchos le
llaman ya prima que por cierto para no
irnos confundiendo voy a poner allí
prima de color rosa ye prima va a ser la
ye prima rosada y bueno ahora que tengo
ahora nuestro calcular la derivada de la
izquierda cierto cierto entonces me
queda elevada a la x de cuadrada que
multiplica a la derivada con respecto a
x de una multiplicación de funciones por
lo tanto primero derivó la primera
función que es la derivada de x con
respecto a x lo cual es 1 y lo
multiplicó por la segunda función que ya
cuadrada entonces me queda solamente y
el cuadrada más la derivada de la
segunda función con respecto a x por la
primera función
entonces pongo x que es la primera
función por la derivada de la segunda
función con respecto a x pero esto ya lo
hemos hecho varias veces utilizando la
regla de la cadena me queda dos veces
por mi prima es decir por la derivada de
ye gon respecto a x la derivada de ella
con respecto a x está de color rosa y s
prima y bueno esto es igual a 1 menos de
prima
a 1 - y prima de color rosa y a
continuación lo que quiero hacer es
multiplicar el elevado a la x de
cuadrada tanto por el primer factor como
por el segundo factor voy a distribuir
esta multiplicación entonces me queda es
elevada a la x de cuadrada que
multiplica a ye cuadrada pues es lo
mismo que ye cuadrada que multiplica ha
elevado a xy cuadrada más y después
tengo 2 por ye por x me queda 2x y que
multiplica a su vez ha elevado a la x de
cuadrada por ye prima y esto va a ser
igual del otro lado sigue quedando todo
sin ningún cambio
1 - y prima y bueno recuerden que lo que
siempre busco es despejar allí prima por
lo tanto voy a juntar términos comunes
aquí está y prima la voy a pasar sumando
del otro lado
entonces me queda más 1 y prima y aquí
pues le tengo que sumar y prima y éste
que está aquí lo voy a pasar del otro
lado restando por lo tanto voy a poner
aquí menos y el cuadrada elevado a la
equis
y del otro lado también lo voy a poner
con signo negativo me va a quedar o no
igual a menos cuadrada y elevado a la
equis y cuadrada voy a realizar las
operaciones correspondientes en cada
parte de la igualdad en la primera se
cancela todo esto y solamente me queda
2x de x a la equis de cuadrada más 1
todo esto a su vez multiplica aie prima
lo único que hice fue sumar este + este
y sacar factor común y bueno del otro
lado de la igualdad tengo que una prima
negativa y una de prima positiva y por
lo tanto se van entonces solamente me va
a quedar términos que no dependen de la
derivada de ella con respecto a x me
queda 1 menos 10 cuadrada elevado a la x
cuadrada y bueno ahora lo que quiero
despejar allí prima por lo tanto todo
esto que está aquí lo voy a pasar
dividiendo y me queda vamos a hacer la
magia de cortar y pegar por lo tanto voy
a intentar agarrarlo aquí no se puede
agarrar bien voy a intentar o creo que
no se puede
es decir el que se me ocurre no lo voy a
escribir otra vez a mano me queda uno
menos ya cuadrada
a la equis cuadrada no puede ser trampa
esta vez entre 212 un poco más grande
2x james que multiplica ha elevado a la
equis de cuadrada más uno y ya hemos
acabado ya con esto logramos obtener lo
que queríamos y aunque esta derivada
parece ser un poco más loca que las
demás no es distinta a todo lo que hemos
hecho en los ejercicios anteriores